in an exclusive interview Brittany
griner's wife tells us she is terrified
about the end about the WNBA Superstar
fate we spoke with shirelle Griner
yesterday this was her first interview
since Brittany Greiner was sentenced to
nine years in a Russian prison she was
arrested you may recall back in February
at a Moscow airport after authorities
found cannabis Vape cartridges in her
luggage a Russian Court will hear an
appeal of her conviction later this
month yesterday the White House called
the appeal another sham judicial
proceeding and said President Biden is
telling his administration to engage
with the Russian government at all
levels to bring Greiner home immediately
so he went to griner's home she lives in
Phoenix where shirelle told us feels
like her wife is stuck in a hostage
situation
it's like a movie for me I'm like in no
world that I ever thought you know our
president and a foreign nation president
would be sitting down having to discuss
the freedom of my wife and so to me as
much as everybody's telling me
a different definition of what BG is it
feels to me as if she's a hostage
that must scare you it terrifies me
because
I mean when you watch movies like
sometimes those situations don't end
well sometimes they never get the person
back so this is not a movie though
exactly and this is my life and so I'm
sitting there like do we get her back do
I ever get to see my wife again like
what happens here the fact that
everything's so unprecedented and
everything's like
changeable I think is a really good word
like I feel like every day I'm hearing
something new and so it's just kind of
like it's terrifying
oh boy tomorrow we'll have more of our
exclusive conversation with shirelle
Griner including a story from her last
conversation with Brittany after her
sentencing it left shirelle very
concerned and as she said crying in her
bed for three days she used the word
terrified yes did you sense that she had
any hope well she has to have hope she
said I don't have any choice but to have
hope I asked her Nick how are you still
standing how are you sitting here
coherent think about this two guys she
was studying for the bar while all this
is going on she's she'll know in a
couple weeks if she passed the bar she
said I don't have any other choice but
to carry on and be the voice for my wife
and and not lose hope so yes she very
much has hope she believes that every
the levels at the highest level of our
government are working on it well the
law means different things in this
country exactly right about that exactly